bonjour Stéphane Artano merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous pendant cette première
demi-heure et lutte
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon membre du
groupe Rassemblement démocratique et
social européen président de la
délégation sénatoriale aux outre-mer et
on a beaucoup de sujets à aborder avec
vous on commence par la crise sanitaire
qui a provoqué des tensions dans les
territoires d'outre-mer notamment sur la
question d'obligation vaccinale pour les
soignants hier le ministre de la Santé
François Brune a dit qu'il y avait un
problème de santé et d'éthique à
réintégrer les soignants dont vaccinés
vous êtes d'accord avec ça on peut
l'entendre quand on est en période de
crise et tension au sein de nos hôpitaux
aujourd'hui on voit bien que les choses
se détendent et chichent un parallèles
avec l'impayé que je connais assez bien
près de mon territoire quel Canada ils
ont complètement déverrouillé notamment
les exigences à la gare de ceux qui
n'étaient pas vaccinés pour les
réintégrer aujourd'hui pendant la crise
covid je crois que c'est 15000 soignants
qui ont été suspendus 6000 pompiers et
je crois que le ministre un peu avoué
elle a un peu avoué il a du mal
d'ailleurs à quantifier le nombre de
Soyons suspendus aujourd'hui moi je veux
bien mais quand on voit la tension dans
nos hôpitaux je crois qu'à un moment
donné le réalisme politique et le
respect qu'on doit nos soignants et à
nos patients pour pouvoir les réintégrer
on n'est plus on parle de tension et je
pense que là le on est le gouvernement
est sur ce sujet un peu en mode idée
fixe si vous voulez ce qui est un peu
dommage c'est très très bien ce que je
dis mais c'est quand même moi je suis
quand même assez frappé par le manque de
lucidité par rapport à ce que vivent nos
soignants et aux cris d'alarme de tous
les services d'urgence dans certains
sont obligés de fermer et qu'à un moment
donné il faut prendre des mesures et la
réintégration devrait pouvoir permettre
de répondre à ça
aujourd'hui donc par la traditionnelle
journée et consacrée aux autres mères le
ministre Jean-François caraco sera
présent et on va parler d'abord du
pouvoir d'achat comme ailleurs en
métropole la préoccupation est forte
autour de la vie chère et des hausses de
prix mais d'autant plus forte que les
coûts des produits de première nécessité
sont plus élevées que le taux de
pauvreté 2 à 5 fois plus élevé qu'en
métropole quelle mesure doit prendre le
gouvernement il y a déjà un bouclier
qualité prix il doit être étendu pour
vous c'est une des préconisations du
gouvernement dans un certain nombre de
territoires priori le ministre devrait
annoncer cette semaine à ce qu'il
l'appelle le ludinot de la vie chère les
premiers effets de cette extension je ne
sais pas si ce sera suffisant si je
prends l'exemple de Saint-Pierre Milan
que je connais un peu mieux évidemment
quand l'inflation depuis l'année 2000
dans l'Hexagone et 33% chez nous avec 66
quand en juillet 2022 vous êtes à 5 nous
on est à 9 et qu'à un moment donné même
agrandir augmenter le bouclier qualité
prix qui est quand même très limité en
nombre de produits et en nombre de
surface commerciale concernées je ne
sais pas si ce sera suffisant je pense
qu'il y a d'autres sujets qui sont sur
la table notamment liés à
l'approvisionnement des matières
premières la cheminement des conteneurs
par exemple quand vous savez que les
conteneurs sont passés de 1500 euros à
5000 voire même à 9000 tout ça c'est
répercuté sur le consommateur final et
négocier avec CMA CGM comme le
gouvernement de la fée c'est très bien
mais il a les territoires qui ne font
pas l'objet de ces négociations et pour
lesquelles les problèmes existent il y a
un autre sujet évidemment c'est la crise
énergétique et la hausse des prix de
l'énergie à Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
notamment chez vous l'hiver et rudes
est-ce que vous êtes inquiet de cette
hausse des prix de l'énergie pour les
ménages est-ce que les aides sont
suffisantes je suis inquiet on a alerté
à plusieurs reprises quand vous savez
que sur une année le prix du fioul
domestique c'est quand même 40% du
budget déménage sur mon territoire et
passer de 0,65 centimes à 1,20 vous
faites au calcul sur ce que ça
représente vous passez par exemple de
1800 euros pour une maison à 3000 euros
et il y a des ménages qui n'ont pas les
moyens de se payer et qui se prennent ça
de plein fouet on a demandé un blocage
du prix du fioul à 0 65 centimes d'euro
le ministre qu'un Inco interrogé au
Sénat le 6 octobre s'est engagé à faire
étudier
la possibilité parce que c'est lui qui
fixe le prix du fioul on n'a pas eu de
réponse pour l'instant et on vient de
saisir avec mon collègue député Stéphane
Lenorman le gouvernement à nouveau
Gérald Darmanin en l'occurrence et
Jean-François caraco pour obtenir ces
éléments toujours pas de réponse il y a
eu un dispositif d'aide qui a été mis en
place et qui ne concerne qu'une partie
de la population nous on aimerait
l'élargir et qu'on est vraiment un
blocage sur le prix vous savez ça ça
rejoint un peu ce qui s'est fait sur le
prix de l'essence dans l'Hexagone l'aide
à la pompe n'a pas été tendu sur tous
les territoires ultramarins parce qu'on
a des producteurs et des distributeurs
indépendants et le gouvernement l'as
assumé d'ailleurs en disant on ne veut
pas créer de troubles sociaux pour ces
producteurs qui seraient mis en
difficulté je pense qu'il y a des
dispositifs à réinventer
vraisemblablement on va parler d'un
autre sujet qui sera d'ailleurs des
sujets de préoccupation majeurs de votre
journée c'est la question du logement
Alex tout ça va nous rejoindre pour nous
faire le point sur les chiffres
[Musique]
et Alex le logement est un enjeu crucial
pour les populations ultramarines
effectivement un enjeu à remettre dans
le contexte de la pauvreté regardez ces
chiffres de la pauvreté en outre-mer
selon la dernière enquête sur ce sujet
de l'INSEE en 2017 et bien à Mayotte il
y avait 77% de Mahorais qui vivaient
sous le seuil national de pauvreté à 34%
des Guadeloupéens pour 14 % en France
métropolitaine alors le logement c'est
donc une réponse à cette urgence de la
pauvreté et la réponse n'est pas à la
hauteur il y a 80% des ultramarins qui
sont éligibles à un logement social et
parmi ces personnes éligibles seulement
15% réside actuellement dans le parc
social c'est donc clairement insuffisant
et on va le voir il y a un besoin de
construction de logements si on prend le
parc de logement global dans les
départements et régions d'outre-mer il y
a 984 000 logements dont près de 172000
logements sociaux mais il y a un besoin
de construction de 90 000 logements
sociaux supplémentaires et même plus de
100 000 si on ajoute les collectivités
d'outre-mer donc pour faire face à cette
situation ces dernières années les
pouvoirs publics ont fixé
l'objectif de construire chaque année 10
000 logements sociaux supplémentaires
mais le compte n'y est pas si on prend
les dernières années par exemple le
nombre de logements sociaux financés en
outre-mer prêt à être construit en 2000
à 16 il était à 662 et en 2021 il a donc
baissé il est à
4793 on peut également aussi ajouter
l'urgence de rénover réhabiliter
certains logements en outre-mer qui sont
vétus qui ne sont pas aux normes et ce
week-end d'ailleurs au Sénat lors de
l'examen du budget 2023 et bien les
sénateurs ont voté un élargissement du
crédit d'impôt pour pouvoir réhabiliter
son logement en outre-mer Stéphane
Artano a d'abord un mot sur le constat
cette crise du logement d'outre-mer elle
participe de la situation de pauvreté
des populations complètement le logement
c'est un facteur essentiel et c'est vrai
que dans le rapport sénatorial qui a été
rendu sur ce sujet en 2021 donc les
lions alors avec les trois rapporteurs
pour réinventer la politique logement et
notamment la territorialiser ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui on voit que
c'est une politique très verticale qui
vient de Paris et on a souhaité
effectivement impliquer plus les
collectivités sur leur territoire
écoutez les acteurs sur leur territoire
et j'espère sincèrement que au moment où
le prochain plan logement outre-mer
puisse être mis en place que cette que
ces appels du pied on a quand même 77
recommandations dans ce rapport pourront
être mises en œuvre ou être entendu et
qu'un dialogue pourra s'instaurer avec
le gouvernement on va parler des
objectifs de construction de logements
mais d'abord un mot sur l'état des
logements actuels un problème de vétusté
de qualité de l'habitat en outre-mer il
y a un vrai sujet sur la vétusté vous
l'avez dit notamment sur l'insuffisance
du nombre de logements et notamment sur
les 110 000 logements qui sont dit
illicites voire même insalubre et je
pense que là effectivement on a un vrai
sujet la politique dit de résorption de
l'habitat indigne est insuffisamment
développé on l'a encore dénoncé ce
week-end lors de l'examen du PF au Sénat
et j'espère évidemment que ça pourra se
traduire concrètement dans les mesures
qui seront prises par le gouvernement
est-ce que l'accompagnement sur ses
moyens pour le logement l'accompagnement
de l'État est suffisant actuellement
je ne dirais pas qu'il faut forcément
plus de crédit parce que c'est souvent
ce qui est dit je crois qu'il y a
souvent des blocages techniques
également sur ces dossiers qu'on vous
commenciez un dossier d'habitat logement
social par exemple pour me prendre que
celui-là ça peut prendre 3 à 4 années
avant d'aboutir et puis vous avez le
problème de l'adaptation des normes qui
a été pointu du doigt quand même par le
sénateur parce que les normes dans
chacun de nos territoires sont
différents les matériaux et les circuits
courts donc on a un véritable sujet sur
ce sur ce point-là sur lequel on a émis
un certain nombre de préconisations
également pour une meilleure prise en
considération et la construction de
circuits courts faire confiance aux
acteurs locaux mais vous l'avez dit
effectivement il y a un vrai problème de
niveau il y a des cris d'alarme qui ont
été lancés notamment par mes collègues
comme Catherine Concorde lors de
l'examen du PLF on espère qu'à terme ils
seront tendus et que de nouveaux
dispositifs puissent être imaginés parce
que ce ne sont pas forcément au cœur de
nos villes ça peut être dans des petits
quartiers dans des petits bourgs à
l'extérieur qui échappent au dispositif
nationaux que ces situations sont
constatées et auxquelles il faut pouvoir
répondre donc ces objectifs de
construction de logement en outre-mer
qui ne sont pas atteints vous
l'expliquez aussi par ces lourdeurs
administratives ces problèmes de normes
ça fait partie des explications elles
sont multiples puisque c'est un sujet
qui est complexe mais effectivement ça
fait partie des images que nous avons
identifié
et Monsieur sintori évidemment un autre
sujet de préoccupation c'est la question
de la sécurité Alex on va voir avec vous
les chiffres de l'insécurité dans les
autres mains oui on va regarder les
statistiques de la délinquance en 2021
qui sont publiés par le ministère de
l'Intérieur en comparant les taux
d'infraction pour 1000 habitants dans
les départements et régions d'outre-mer
donc pas dans tous les territoires
ultramarins comme par exemple
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon je le précise
premier type d'infraction à observer les
cambriolages on voit par exemple quand
Guyane il y a 12 cambriolages chaque
année pour 1000 habitants c'est un taux
qui est deux fois supérieur à celui de
la France entière ou par exemple on a
5,2 cambriolages pour 1000 habitants et
on voit qu'en Martinique et à la Réunion
et bien les taux de cambriolages sont
inférieurs à celui de la France entière
mais pour ce qui est de l'infraction de
coûts et blessures volontaires et bien
là les chiffres de l'outre-mer ne sont
pas bons les taux de coûts et blessures
sont supérieurs à la France entière quel
que soit le département et la région
d'outre-mer et notamment en Guadeloupe
et en Guyane ou ses inf sont nombreuses
et puis les écarts sont aussi
saisissants quand on regarde les vols
avec armes de vol avec armes pour 1000
habitants chaque année à Mayotte 3,6 en
Guyane c'est nettement supérieur par
rapport à auto dans la France entière un
taux qui n'est que de
0,13 et puis pour un certain type de
violences particulières les violences
sexuelles la population égale et bien il
y en a davantage dans les départements
et régions d'outre-mer plutôt que dans
la totalité du pays c'est la même
situation par exemple pour les violences
intrafamiliales deux types de violences
qui sont en explosion ces dernières
années dans ces territoires Stéphane
Artano comment vous expliquer ce haut
niveau de violence en outre-mer écoutez
il y a au moins une explication qui me
saute aux yeux quand je vois vos
graphiques ce sont les deux territoires
qui sortent de l'eau la Guyane et
Mayotte et qui sont tous les deux des
territoires transfrontaliers et sur
lequel se posent un véritable sujet sur
l'immigration clandestine et donc ça
c'est vrai que ces chiffres le mettent
en évidence je crois qu'il y a une
déshérence et puis on l'a dit le niveau
de pauvreté pousse sans doute les gens à
des actes de de criminalité plus
importante dans nos territoires et puis
Christian Combon l'a dit il y a quelques
jours sur ce sujet les outre-mer ont
besoin de plus d'État sur l'aspect
régalien je pense qu'il faut être très
clair sur ce sujet aujourd'hui la
réponse parce que l'État est défaillante
dans les outre-mer oui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une part de
responsabilité de l'État et je ne tire
pas à vous les rouges sur l'étage je
pense qu'il y a une part de
responsabilité des collectivités qui
doivent aussi être aux côtés de leur
population puisque on le voit dans
l'Hexagone là où ça fonctionne c'est
quand les collectivités sont impliquées
sur le terrain sur le terrain notamment
auprès des jeunes pour faire des actions
de prévention et je pense qu'il y a une
réponse multiple en fait qu'il faut
apporter mais c'est assez éloquent de
voir que la Guyane et Mayotte
effectivement sont pleinement frappés au
regard de l'immigration qui est un vrai
sujet de mon point de vue sur ces
territoires on va revenir sur le cas de
Mayotte un spécifiquement oui donc selon
où il y a une réponse de proximité à
apporter mais par exemple au Parlement
en ce moment il y a le débat sur le
projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'intérieur avec la création de 15000 de
fait que 15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires en budget 8500 postes de
forces de l'ordre créée donc vous
demandez vraiment que des postes de
force de l'ordre soient affectés dans
les outre-mer je crois que beaucoup de
sénateurs ultrama demande effectivement
un renforcement des moyens de
gendarmerie ou de police sur nos
territoires pour effectivement assurer
la population je crois d'ailleurs que
les mères Mayotte en en reparlera ont
lancé un cri d'alerte il y a pas si
longtemps que ça qui est assez éloquent
et qui doit être entendu au plus haut
niveau et sur la question de
l'immigration il aura la loi immigration
de Darmanin au début de l'année 2023
examiné au Parlement est-ce que vous
demandez des lois spécifiques pour la
Guyane et Mayotte pour ces territoires
par rapport au reste du territoire
national bah vous regardez le débat qui
a lieu actuellement au Conseil
constitutionnel sur Mayotte il y a eu un
dispositif sur le contrôle d'identité
sur le territoire qui fait l'objet d'une
censure possible ou pas par le Conseil
constitutionnel oui effectivement il
faut vraisemblablement adapter la
réponse dans la mesure où l'État a été
défendu en un moment donné comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour rectifier le tir
et apporter les réponses et sécuriser
ses territoires
en déplacement à Mayotte fin août et qui
a dit qu'il voulait durcir le droit du
sol à Mayotte vous le soutenez oui mais
le président de la République un peu
modéré ses propos le 7 septembre à
l'Élysée lors de la rencontre avec les
parlementaires ultramarins en disant
qu'il fallait également que la réponse
vienne des Comores c'est à dire qu'il y
a une réponse diplomatique que doit
enclencher l'état je ne suis pas
persuadé aujourd'hui que cette réponse
là est encore porter ses fruits du coup
Alex on va rester sur Mayotte et on
revient après avec vous sur l'aspect
plus général puisque vous le disait à un
endroit c'est un endroit où les
questions de sécurité se posent encore
plus qu'ailleurs un taux de délinquance
beaucoup plus élevé qu'en métropole on
va écouter l'ancien président du conseil
départemental de Mayotte Daniel Zeidi
vous le savez nous sommes passés en
l'espace de quelques années d'une île
au parfum à une île en sauvagée et
aujourd'hui on fait face à la bestialité
de nos agresseurs il est incontestable
aujourd'hui que l'État a échoué dans la
surveillance de nos frontières elle n'a
pas le droit des déchets sur la sécurité
des biens et des personnes sur le
territoire de Mayotte les moyens qui
n'ont pas été mis de manière suffisante
sur les frontières doivent être mis sur
la sécurité des personnes à Mayotte il y
a deux choses on se dit l'histoire du
contrôle des frontières va y revenir et
l'histoire de la sécurité des biens et
des personnes au sein même du territoire
Gérald Darmanin qui est allé on le
disait sur l'île fin août annoncé un
quatrième escadron de gendarme et a
rappelé qu'il y avait déjà eu une
augmentation des moyens de 50% de
policiers et de gendarmes est-ce qu'on
peut dire que l'État est défaillant je
pense que les chiffres parlent
d'eux-mêmes mais et c'est pas faire un
jure à ce gouvernement ou un autre je
pense que depuis la départementalisation
de Mayotte on a eu beaucoup de mal à
oublier le phénomène et l'ABS de
sécurité n'a fait qu'augmenter on a reçu
avec le président Larcher une élégation
des mères de Mayotte qui sont
complètement désœuvrés sur ce sujet et
qui ont voulu on s'inscrit d'alarme
parce qu'ils sont ils sont mis en
difficulté au titre de leur propre
sécurité personnelle certains ont été en
fait l'objet d'agression et les
populations locales le vivent
extrêmement mal et je pense sincèrement
que la réponse de l'État n'a pas été à
la hauteur et elle ne l'est pas encore
aujourd'hui je pense qu'à un moment
donné la question de l'immigration
clandestine et de retour sur les Comores
des personnes qui sont en situation
légale va également se poser devra
également être traité la question de
l'accouchement de ces femmes qui
viennent accoucher en territoire
français pour des raisons absolument et
un documentaire qui sera tourné bientôt
là-dessus ce sera intéressant de le voir
mais effectivement je pense qu'il y a un
vrai dialogue à avoir été Comores j'ai
pas le sentiment que pour l'instant les
Comores et envie qu'on discute avec eux
enfin moi c'est le sentiment que j'ai de
l'extérieur et qu'à un moment donné la
France est quand même une puissance
importante elle devra également imposer
ces conditions du dialogue mais je pense
que ça passera aussi par la voie
diplomatique mais pas que je pense qu'il
y a deux francs à aborder aujourd'hui je
n'en vois qu'un de manière un peu timide
sur les moyens qui sont renforcés on
peut s'enorgueillir mais c'est
insuffisant au regard de des dérapages
et vous verrez que les chiffres vont
continuer à progresser malgré les
alertes lancées par les élus et puis
derrière l'action diplomatique qui pour
l'instant est relativement timide en
tout cas les résultats ne sont pas ne
sont pas au grand jour
j'avais une question sur la réforme de
la police qui est très critiquée en ce
moment et c'est une réforme qui va
fusionner au sein d'un même département
les différents services de police par
exemple la police aux frontières la
police judiciaire la police de sécurité
publique une réforme qui a été
expérimentée notamment en Guyane est-ce
que ça peut être une solution à
l'insécurité cette réorganisation de la
police au delà des dogmes mais des
aspects philosophiques que cette
question peut poser je pense que c'est
l'efficacité sur le terrain qui prime
avant tout et effectivement si ça a
démontré une efficacité en Guyane
peut-être que ça peut démontrer une
efficacité à Mayotte je pense que
l'expérimentation ultra-marine peut
permettre ce type d'évolution ici
effectivement cette solution a permis du
résultat je pense qu'il faudra
vraisemblablement aller vers là mais
sans en tirer forcément une enseignement
pour l'ensemble de l'hexagone puisque
les situations sont multiples et
diverses sur ces territoires est-ce
qu'il y a aussi une inquiétude à avoir
sur certains de violence notamment les
violences sexuelles les violences
intrafamilales qui sont en explosion ces
dernières années en outre-mer oui
absolument je pense que c'est un
véritable sujet d'ailleurs la délégation
au droit des femmes et la délégation
sénatale aux outre-mer va mener un
travail sur l'accompagnement la
parentalité en outre-mer je pense que il
y a là un vrai véritable sujet de
société que nous devons ces courants
2023 c'est un sujet qui nous interpelle
beaucoup et qui fait peut-être partie
des réponses soyez c'est pas seulement
une réponse policière il y a aussi une
réponse sociale et sociétale à apporter
pour accompagner ces mouvements
à tout à l'heure on parlera de la cour à
la course à la présidence du parti de la
République voilà ce sera vivre dans le
fleuve dans une grosse demi-heure merci
beaucoup Alex on parlait justement avec
Alex de toutes ces questions la vie
chère la crise du logement l'insécurité
est-ce que pour vous c'est ce qui
explique les scores élevés de Marine Le
Pen à la présidentielle dans les
territoires d'outre-mer exceptés dans le
Pacifique elle est arrivée largement en
tête dans tous les autres territoires il
y a déjà eu une cristallisation autour
du nom d'Emmanuel Macron qu'on le
veuille ou pas le président à
cristallisé à mécontentement fort il y a
effectivement une situation liée à
l'obligation vaccinale qui n'a pas été
comprise depuis Paris dans certains de
nos territoires je dis bien dans
certains de nos territoires et pas dans
tous les territoires il y a
effectivement un discours que le RN
apportait à Mayotte qui était un
discours anticomore qui était assez
porteur à l'égard de la population et
puis on voit bien la porosité entre les
électorats puisque l'appel a voté et les
filles à ne pas se reporter sur le RN
n'a pas été entendu parce qu'il y a eu
un report massif et quand même le la
reine est arrivé dans cette département
on numéro un au deuxième tour donc ça
interpelle et Martial Foucault de
Sciences Po de la chair outre-mer
analyse assez bien ce scrutin et les
résultats se scrutin c'est un rejet mais
il n'y a pas qu'un rejet moi qui
m'inquiète quand on voit l'évolution du
score du RN en outre-mer depuis
maintenant quelques années notamment
avec les Européennes et cette fois-ci de
la présidentielle ça doit interpeller
quand même sur le fait qu'un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens adhèrent à ces
thèse qui sont pour moi des thèses qui
sont extrêmes et je lutte contre ces
extrêmes et ça doit interpeller la
classe politique quand on a été invité à
l'Élysée le 7 septembre je n'ai pas
entendu de la bouche du président de la
République et j'aurais aimé l'entendre
la restauration du pacte républicain
outre-mer comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
dans 5 ans à cette élection
présidentielle qui va venir en 2027 qui
est pour moi l'élection de tous les
dangers pour notre pays les
ultramarins puissent revenir aux ions et
puissent revenir aux urnes vers des
mouvements républicains qui portent les
valeurs de la République comment est-ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
entendu ce débats là et pour moi il est
pleinement posé sur la table et je ne
vois pas encore le bout du tunnel je
pense qu'on se disperse parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de sujets en outre-mer et je
pense qu'il faudrait sans doute
prioriser par territoire pour pouvoir
apporter des réponses et démontrer et
restaurer la confiance dans la politique
publique et les pouvoirs publics de
manière générale ça veut dire
qu'Emmanuel Macron que vous avez
rencontré l'Élysée en septembre n'a pas
pris conscience où il méconnait
finalement les spécificités des
territoires ultramarins je me pose la
question humainement on peut comprendre
qu'effectivement le score qu'il a fait à
cette élection puisse le refroidir je
pense que c'est maintenant sa
responsabilité de pouvoir reconstituer
ce facteur républicain le réinvestir si
c'est pas lui qui le réinvestit je pense
que d'autres partis politiques devront
le faire pour démontrer que la France
s'intéresse également
de toute façon c'est pas sans la
victoire
rapide et puis et puis lapitter mais je
suis que j'ai été surpris quand même de
ne pas l'avoir entendu cette resto à
cette volonté de restaurer de pacte
républicains on a plus répondu à
différents problèmes des Outre-mer mais
c'est au moins un problème de fond que
personne n'ose on a l'impression que
personne n'ose le mettre sur la table
quoi et ça reste quand même le sujet de
mon point de vue pour les années à venir
on va parler d'un territoire spécifique
c'est la Nouvelle-Calédonie puisque
Gérald Darmanin va s'y rendre la semaine
prochaine avec le ministre des outre-mer
pour lancer les groupes de travail sur
l'avenir institutionnel de Lille après
trois référendum disons non à
l'indépendance des discussions au lieu à
matinons avec les acteurs
institutionnels de Lille mais sans les
indépendantistes qui n'ont pas souhaité
venir on va écouter à ce sujet Gérald
Darmanin il était auditionné par le
Sénat de novembre dernier
il y a un sujet qui est un sujet
difficile pour les indépendantistes
c'est la première fois depuis très
longtemps qui ne sont pas dans une
situation où justement il y a un
référendum d'autodétermination certains
à quelques mois ou quelques années près
et je pense que ça crée une difficulté
bien sûr dans le camp indépendantiste
nous devons respecter nous devons
l'accompagner nous devons montrer notre
porte est toujours ouverte il ne s'agit
du billet absolument personne on est
prêt à discuter de plein de sujets mais
on ne peut pas faire comme si ces trois
référendum n'avaient pas dit par trois
fois que les Calédoniens voulaient
rester dans la République française vous
comprenez la position des
indépendantistes qui invitaient à venir
dialoguer à Matignon avec Elizabeth
borne refuse d'attendre oui bien sûr je
pense qu'il faut respecter effectivement
cette sociologie locale qui est propre
d'ailleurs à chacun des territoires et
donc moi je peux comprendre que nos amis
calaisoniens et ce débat sur leur
territoire mais je crois objectivement
pour être tout à fait sincère la
solution elle viendra de l'or territoire
les discussions elles devront être
menées sur leur territoire et le fait
que les deux ministres s'y rendent je
pense que c'est un bon signe mais je
crois également que les deux camps
dentiste non indépendantiste doivent
purger quand même les quelques années de
tension après cette volonté on sait
aujourd'hui que la Nouvelle-Calédonie
restera dans la République française et
moi je prône évidemment cet appartenance
à la République dans un cadre qui va
être peut-être rénové mais cette
discussion elle doit avoir lieu entre
ces deux grandes tendances politiques
sur le territoire alors peut-être que
les ateliers vont permettre d'avancer
mais je crois qu'ils devront se dire un
peu les choses quitte à ce que les
portes se claquent quittent à ce qu'on
se fasse un peu la tête et qu'on
revienne à la table mais je crois que la
solution elle est en Nouvelle-Calédonie
sur leur territoire entre ces deux
mouvements vous croyez un accord local
je pense que tout le monde le souhaite
on peut comprendre qu'il y a une phase
d'observation on peut comprendre qu'il y
ait un peu d'amertume il y a d'histoire
il faut pas oublier comment les
différents accords ont été bâtis
d'ailleurs ils n'ont pas été construits
à Paris ils ont été construit sur le
territoire avec tout tes sensibilité en
tenant compte de cet ancrage territorial
en tenant compte de la coutume et je
crois que c'est par là que ça passera ça
veut dire que c'est une erreur qui a
fait Elisabeth band de demander aux
attentes tunnels de venir à Matignon
c'est elle qui aurait dû se rendre sur
place je ne sais pas vous savez il faire
preuve de beaucoup d'humilité sur ce sur
ce sujet sur ce dossier personne
n'aurait peut-être fait mieux il y a un
cadre qui a été piloté par la première
ministre elle l'a fait le ministre
Darmanin lors de cette audition
d'ailleurs à annoncé les différentes
avancées qu'on permis ces rencontres
peut-être insuffisantes mais je crois
objectivement qu'au-delà du pilotage par
matinion et par l'état de manière
générale c'est la Nouvelle-Calédonie qui
devra trouver la troisième voie celle
qui pour l'instant n'a pas encore été
trouvée et en tout cas c'est la voie de
la République dans un cadre peut-être
rénové qui est mis intérieur et des
Outre-mer en passent toute la semaine
prochaine là-bas c'est un bon signal
pour vous il est ministre d'État et
c'est important qu'il le sapient dans le
processus moi j'ai beaucoup aimé ces
déclarations lors de l'audition devant
la commission des lois alors récemment
et j'espère effectivement qu'il pourra
apporter un message d'espoir et j'espère
surtout qu'ils pourront trouver sur leur
territoire la manière de pouvoir arriver
à enfin s'entendre quitte à dire qu'on
n'est pas d'accord surtout mais pouvoir
trouver cette troisième loi un dernier
mot puisque cette journée des Outre-mer
est elle se décline en deux temps ce
matin il y aura une rencontre entre les
maires des outre-mer et puis cet
après-midi vous serez au Sénat pour un
après-midi une après-midi de travail
vous faites partie du groupe de travail
décentralisation qui a été lancé par
Gérard Larcher au mois d'octobre vous en
êtes où votre avant délégation quasiment
achevée l'audition de tous les exécutifs
ultramarins sur
le fait d'avoir revisité le rapport de
Michel Magra qui a été rendu en 2020 sur
la différentiation entre mer une
différenciation d'ailleurs qui peut se
poser également pour l'Hexagone de
manière générale pour toute la France
donc on a quasiment terminé nos
auditions on continuera évidemment à
construire les recommandations de la
délégation et puis j'aurai le plaisir de
rapporter devant ce groupe de travail
présidé par le président marché les
différentes recommandations que nous
allons émettre avant que le Sénat puisse
continuer à travailler sur la
décentralisation au sens large et rentre
et rendre son rapport courant 2023 merci
stéphaneau merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous on suivra bien sûr cette
journée des Outre-mer aujourd'hui sur
notre antenne merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité dans 20 minutes dans lequel
des territoires on reviendra sur un
course à la présidence des républicains
peut-être décisif ce sera ce soir entre
les trois candidats Éric sur Aurélien
Pradier et Bruno Retailleau et d'abord
on va accueillir notre invité politique
c'est David Lisnard qui nous rejoint